hello everyone and welcome to round 13
of the 1970 palm and Americans rezoning
tournament after five rounds of four
draws and one loss Fischer finally got a
win against nine hundred and F and
Geller I was a really a tough game
probably lasted for six or seven hours
in a completely the wrong position
Fischer was able to push for the win and
finally win the game now he faces one of
the you were Slavia strongest
grandmasters it's Borislav f-cove Serbia
and definitely definitely a tough game
as if Koval was a three times
Yugoslavian champion he represented
Yugoslavia in 12 chess olympiad he he
qualified for the Interzone tournaments
five times and he participated in the
1965 candidates tournament so definitely
definitely a strong player and for those
of you who are interested in some trivia
on the side borstal f-cove is actually
the first-ever World Junior Chess
Champion in 1951 there was a World
Junior Chess Championship organized in
Birmingham and borislav if Cove won that
event so he is the first-ever World
Junior Chess Champion so and for those
of you who are interested in some extra
trivia on the side add the only player
ever to win the World Junior Chess
Championship twice junior means under 20
years old is actually shocked there mama
the earth so there you have it your vast
knowledge has just been slightly
increased now let's check out the dis
game it's quite a lovely game something
serious Fischer's best game in the in
this tournament but before that we do
have a nice photo challenge so who are
the two gentlemen in this photo so there
we have it
best of luck to everyone now let's check
out the game it's a pretty much
theoretical line tell some tents move so
let's just check it out efore
d5 William Knight to f3 sorry about that
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule
opus a6 attacking the bishop so Murphy's
defensive Bishop to a4 Knight to f6 we
have castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1 b5
Bishop to b3 b6 we have c3 making room
for the bishop and c2 also preparing d3
or d4 castles we have a ch3 h6
d for now rook to e8 and Bishop to e3
and here we have a Bishop to f8 a
standard idea knife captures on e4 of
course isn't possible it's not that
official blundered upon here not because
of Bishop captures on h6 but rather
because of Bishop to b5 black simply
loses a piece here so after Bishop to e3
we have Bishop to f8 and now Knight B to
d2 and here better up to b7 is play
simply developing and Queen to be won by
Bobby it's you have to find some sort of
a plan here for example if you simply
capture in the in the center of the
board that's you know relieving the
tension that will only favor black after
Knight captures Knight captures D
captures now black has two very nice
bishops and the queen is free to enter
the game the rooks are able to connect
this would only favor black it would be
the same if instead of Bishop to b7 if
come here captured in the center the end
after C captures you can see that the
white promoted is C pawn into a deep on
black lost the central pawn so only
improve the white central structure so
usually if you don't know why ur
capturing you know there's the old
saying what's the thing to take is a
mistake so if you don't have like a plan
or anything while capturing a piece or a
pawn I you know generally do not do it
so Bishop to b7 Queen to be won by
Fischer and now Queen to b8 we have a
three nights to d8 Maori maneuvering the
night over to e6 Bishop - C - and the
now comes c6 we have B for now Queen to
c7 and now Bishop to d3 a little by
little Fischer is improving the position
of his pieces and so does Eve curve we
have nice to e6 Queen to c2 preparing to
pull the pawn to a4
rook a to c8 and now comes a four we
have Knight to d7
Queen to b3 and now comes Knight to f4
and here you can simply play Bishop to
f1 or Bishop captures to have worship
captures on f4 it's pretty much the same
I don't think any move is better than
the other but
you know if you want to give up the
bishop area immediately you can simply
capture if you wanna you know preserve
everything on the board Bishop 2f1 would
probably be better if it captures it
immediately he doesn't think much of the
bishop pair here but you know as you all
know the LightSquared bishop is Bobby's
favorite piece he captures an eye for
and now see for by Fisher be captures
and see for Bishop captures on c4 and d5
now Fischer plays it Bishop to d3 and
now comes rock back to b8 here you can
see that if Cove has a nice pond on a6
and end on c6 and the Fisher is not able
to put b5 here
so now b5 is Fisher's backwards pawn and
if we will try to create some sort of an
attack against Italy our rook to b8
Queen to b6 and the shop is already
attacking it from FA but similarly if
Fischer has a nice beaver pond d4 pawn
which makes if coves c6 bone a backwards
pawn and Fischer will try to make this
pawn a target again you don't want to
capture in the center this would only
improve the position of whites pieces
and 95 is coming so no point in doing
that rook to b8 and now comes Queen to
c3 getting the Queen out of the pin we
have Queen to b6 now preparing to move
the light square bishop and create a
triple attack against the b4 pawn now
comes Luke 8 B 1 simply defending the
pawn rook to e8 and now as you can see
the bishop the Queen and the rook are
attacking the b4 pawn how do you defend
the pawn there is only one good way to
do it and that is a5 the best idea which
attacks the Queen and it seems that you
can move the Queen Queen to b7 and
that's now black a white cannot defend
the b4 pawn but actually here rock to a4
would the defendant very nicely so
instead after a 5 if Pope doesn't play
Queen b7 rather he plays Queen to a7
we have E 5 here by Fischer and now it's
very hard to find a move for black you
definitely want to create some sort of
an attack against this be for pawn but
it's very hard if you could double rooks
on the B file that would be very nice
but you can't ago Ruby 5 you can't go
rugby 6 you can go Ruby 7 but then you
lose the c6 pawn but that's exactly what
if did he could go for some passive plan
via Bishop to e7 and simply wait for to
see what Bobby will do but white will
have a very nice plan simply a night be
395 here if we will probably have to
open lines and then Bobby will be able
to infiltrate the position so instead of
a passive plan like this if who goes
immediately for rook to b7 and okay he
gives up the c6 pawn queen captures on
c6 and now what do you play if you play
something like rook captures on b4
this does open up an attack against
Fischer's Queen it's a pretty force line
Queen captures on a6 we look after
stumpy one with check rook captures
Queen captures Bishop captures and here
Fischer would be up upon and it would be
a past eight point so pretty much a
winning endgame here
so after Queen to c6 Bishop capture son
before was played a favor still captures
the ACE export we have Queen captures on
a6 and now not trading Queens instead if
curve goes Queen to b8
we have rush up to c2 now this is a
beautiful move by Fischer Bishop to see
to preparing Bishop to a4 it would
create a very powerful pin here but also
making room for the Queen on d3 after
the Queen comes to d3 both Queen and
Bishop will be eyeing the h7 square we
have rook to e6 getting out of the pin
also attacking the Queen Queen 33 now
threatening Queen to h7 and now nice to
f8 guarding the h7 square and here
Fischer here again goes for the
strongest move recommended by the engine
Queen to f5 as simply improving the
position of the Queen and also attacking
the pawn on f4 it's pretty much
impossible to defend the e4 pawn so we
have looked to a6 if goes for the a5
pawn Knight to b3 first Fischer defenses
there's always time to grab the f4 pawn
g6 and now comes Queen captures on f4
and the bush of the c3 attacking
Fischer's rook on a1 and here once again
the Fischer goes for the absolute
strongest move and he calculates
precisely Knight the c5
so what do you do here you can capture
the look on a 1 you can capture the look
on b1 you can capture the rookin be
and then do something there's really a
lot of a lot of ideas here for example
if you capture on a1 then you get route
captures on a1 this is the idea not
capturing or you can capture on b7 with
the night but batteries rope captures on
a1 and now after black tries 96 the idea
is your queen is under attack and you
want to force the whites to capture the
night here but simply knife captures on
a6
after night captures on a4 you capture
blacks Queen and after route captures
here you can see that white is again up
upon its the past a pawn and it's easily
winning endgame so after night to c5
rook captures on a5 rather if we've
grabs the passed pawn we have night
capture some b7 and now rook captures on
a1 rook captures on a1 and now while you
can capture the night immediately beyond
a queen capture some b7 then you'd get
rugby 1 attacking the Queen after Queen
moves Queen captures on h6 again
creating a winning position for white so
instead if of tries first Knight to g6
kind of activating the pieces first
Fischer can capture on h6 rather he
plays Queen to f6
we have Bishop captures on anyone and
the now comes Knight to d6 this was
Fisher's idea he calculated everything
precisely and now you have to see the
beauty of this position if Cove has a
very nice night on e6 but this Knight is
doing very little to actually protect
the black King Fisher is threatening to
capture on f7 with check so how do you
defend this it doesn't matter
Queen to c7 or Queen - FA - both will
defend the pawn but not not very
effectively Quinta's c7 was played in
the game by if Gough and now you can see
if God still has a bishop pair but look
at this bishop pair this bishop pair is
attacking its own pawn on d5 this bishop
pair is stuck
attacking the d4 pawn but there's
nothing it can really do about it so
it's not the greatest pair a bishop pair
in in chess history it's not the worst
the worst is still I think Kasparov
versus Evangeline Linares but not the
greatest definitely
so here Queen to c7 Rose played the f7
point is now defended so I want to
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning move for white here it's a
it's a very nice idea I'm sure you will
see it very quickly so I will give it a
couple of seconds for you to decide if
you want to do it for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
have just found the strongest move
recommended by the engine and for those
of you who just want to enjoy it show
Bishop captures and g6 was played by
Fisher you can also prepare with knife
to h4 doesn't really change anything you
will still win the game but there's no
reason to do it the bishop captures on
g6 and of course if F captures then
Queen captures any sex with check King
moves Queen captures here and now to
defend Knight to f7 this will win blacks
Queen you have to play Queen g7 and now
Knight 12:7 check King moves you can
capture on h6 King moves and now you can
do anything you can play Queen e6 Queen
d6 check and you can pretty much even
exchange Queens as now you're up 4
points and easily winning endgame
so after Bishop captures on g6 if cough
did not capture rather he played Queen
to c1 check the idea is now that after
King h2 if we can exchange Queens
we are Queen to f4 check captures
captures and now okay you can capture
here and after King f8 push e 6 White
would still be winning here but he would
still have to work for it
so instead after this Queen to see one
check Fischer did not play King to h2
rather he played the absolute best move
Knight to e1 a beautiful move with
Knight back a very nice night sacrifice
and there is nothing to do here anymore
Queen captures on f7 followed by h7
checkmate is coming you can only capture
the knight here which was played in the
game this was played the Queen e1 check
Fischer played King to h2 now but now
the Queen can no longer come to f4
so Knight to g5 was played kinda trying
to protect the f7 pawn but it doesn't
work Fischer simply played Bishop
captures on f7 check and it was in this
position that Boris thought if resigned
the game interestingly Queen to d8 will
be checkmate in 4 but Fischer does not
want to check median for he plays Bishop
captures on f7 which is checkmate in
three so why did you resign
whatever he plays is checkmate if you go
King 2h7 then you get Queen d6 check
King moves Queen to g8 checkmate if you
go King to f8 doesn't really matter
Bishop to e6 a discovered check knight
has to block Queen captures on f7 and
lastly after Bishop to f7 if you capture
it you don't capture back you can
capture back it would still win you the
game but quick race Queen to g6 check
and now if King moves here you simply
capture for checkmate or if you move to
h8 the knight captures on f7 will be
checkmate so yeah after this Bishop
captures on f7 move if could resign the
game and another beautiful victory for
for Fischer in around 13 of the 1970
powered America inter-zonal tournament
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it what do you think is it Fischer's
best game so at least so far I don't
know if you've seen all the games from
from this tournament or did you enjoy
some other game we've seen so far better
than this one and once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I do hope you're enjoying
the Bobby Fischer series so far as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here think all for watching and I will
see you soon probably with another game
from the Bobby Fischer series but also
we are continuing the bill chess
festival thank you all and I'll see you
soon